y
[Música]
en momentos de crisis que requerimos un
liderazgo colectivo y transformador que
ese soy leer de algo colectivo ya todos
sabemos que lo más valioso que tiene la
humanidad es el talento humano cómo
cultivar un liderazgo colectivo porque
estamos ya avanzando demasiado en los
liderazgos individuales y esto no
permite que todo el talento humano que
hay detrás de todos nosotros pueda
abrirse y comunicarse y aprovecharlo
para trabajar en comunidad y para que
hacemos esto lo hacemos para que podamos
juntos tener propósitos comunes podamos
trabajar con los mismos valores con
ética probidad transparencia pero además
sería muy importante que nosotros
también las acciones las alineamos con
propósitos valores
y acciones
y que se requiere para estos diálogos
para hacer estos liderazgos la propuesta
es que debemos ser humildes humildes
porque hay que reconocer a los otros su
potencial debemos ser flexibles porque
tenemos que trabajar en ambientes
complejos pero además debemos trabajar
para sumar siempre y con respeto y sobre
todo con respeto por la diferencia esto
es muy importante y dirán ustedes a esos
son sueños de académicos la verdad no es
un sueño académico lo podemos demostrar
lo podemos demostrar cuando construimos
un grupo de profesores de diferencias
áreas un instituto el líder de
biotecnología que apunto al desarrollo
del instituto en un liderazgo colectivo
desde diferentes áreas y con muchas
relaciones internacionales para capturar
conocimiento universal para resolver
problemas de nuestras comunidades y ese
es el instituto de biotecnología de la
universidad nacional de colombia pero de
su instituto así como se fundó también
crea liderazgos colectivos va a poner
dos ejemplos nomás el primer ejemplo es
cómo crear una empresa spin-off eco
innovadora para que las comunidades y
los productores de arroz tengan
biofertilizantes y mejoren sus cosechas
para eso que se hizo definir el
propósito cuál es el propósito producir
biofertilizantes para cultivadores de
arroz y como lo hicimos entonces nos
juntamos la empresa la universidad o sea
la investigación y el desarrollo el
estado que fomenta y el estado que
regula pero también las comunidades y
los usuarios que van a tener el producto
para su beneficio y así lo hicimos y
definimos acciones definimos el
propósito definimos la forma de trabajo
hicimos dos cosas en las acciones la
primera ponernos de acuerdo
y definir qué iba a hacer cada uno y
después de que definimos qué va a hacer
cada uno entonces nosotros nos los
ponemos en común para buscar el mismo
propósito en unas mesas redondas
permanentes de trabajo para ir todos
avanzando al mismo ritmo y así se
construyó una empresa que hoy tiene 10
productos en el mercado desarrollamos
desde el laboratorio la planta piloto y
la empresa otro ejemplo muy importante
con las comunidades y con la mayoría de
edad practicando la escucha activa que
es eso respetar a las comunidades no
podemos ir a invadir las y a decirles
que hagan tenemos que saber que hacen
que quieren y nosotros comprometernos
con que a través del conocimiento y
todos los actores que tienen algo que
ver aporten a las comunidades y en este
caso fue una comunidad productora en ame
en la costa atlántica nos reunimos con
las comunidades le preguntamos qué
necesitan necesitar vestido comida techo
necesitan un cultivo que les dé sustento
que le dé bienestar social y beneficio
económico y a esto le trabajamos
juntamos esfuerzos internacionales
nacionales locales y a las autoridades
responsables de vestido comida y techo
para las comunidades también nos
articulamos al proyecto y en este
momento y después de 14 años que
desarrollamos este proyecto habíamos
pasado a 749 productores asociados en
240 organizaciones que construyeron una
red que se llama la red pro llame y que
se logra se logra la organización su
propio desarrollo empoderarse del
cultivo de de que la ciencia y la
tecnología les sirven a ellos para
mejorar su producción entonces ya en
lugar de 33 mil hectáreas de 33 mil
toneladas año ya se produjeron 400 mil
toneladas año entonces la organización y
el posicionamiento de esa comunidad hace
parte de importantísima del trabajo
porque a veces los citadinos
usamos prepotentemente que le tenemos la
solución a las comunidades la verdad no
es así ellos saben que quieren y cómo
que quieren desarrollar y si queremos
trabajar con ellos tenemos que aceptar
lo que ellos quieren así que eso
significa que nosotros
no es que le vayamos a ayudar es que nos
comprometemos a hacer un diálogo de
saberes para que todos podamos crecer
juntos con estas experiencias de la vida
cotidiana del trabajo entre académicos
en el final con financiadores
internacionales y nacionales y locales
logramos empoderar a una comunidad que
se creó con ellos tres empresas de base
tecnológica de bajo costo y como duro
tanto tiempo el proyecto los los hijos
de ellos se volvieron profesionales y
montaron una empresa exportadora de nam
y se quitaron del medio los
intermediarios y hoy ellos son
sostenibles falta una cosa y es que no
vemos que hay que darle valor agregado y
eso sí no pudimos conseguir la
financiación pero seguimos trabajando
para darle valor agregado
y que es una invitación a que nos
escuchemos a que adquiramos mayor edad
cuando nosotros queremos trabajar con
otros necesitamos saber que el otro
tiene unas necesidades y que no les
vamos a imponer sus necesidades así que
este trabajo colectivo
este trabajo que hacemos en grupo con el
cual podemos crecer todos es el trabajo
que debe multiplicarse porque la
esperanza de salir de la crisis está
realmente en lo que es el trabajo que
podamos hacer para desarrollar
capacidades de liderazgo colectivo en
las comunidades así que como estos
ejemplos podríamos tener millones y
entonces podríamos crecer de manera
equitativa para hacer un país mucho más
equitativo y no tener esos polos de
pobreza y de riqueza que hoy tenemos así
que todos a trabajar en un liderazgo
colectivo y en desarrollar capacidades
de liderazgo colectivo
[Música]
y